so you've got a Hollywood superstar  apparently working on a project that  could maybe take him into outer space  yes remember that line I feel the need  the need for speed NASA is teaming up  with Tom Cruise to create the first  actor driven film to be shot in space it  is set to take place on the  International Space Station Tom Cruise  will reportedly launch into space and  stay aboard the spacecraft SpaceX is  also a potential partner in the film  project which is said to be in the early  prep phase the head of NASA confirmed  the Galactic gig in a tweet saying we  need popular media to inspire a new  generation of engineers and scientists  to make Nash's plans a reality Anthony  Tom Cruise help boost Navy enlistments  in the 80s he'll do it again  thanks Vlad